hola cómo estás hoy y recuerda que hace
un par de vídeos aprendimos que si
comenzábamos con agua sólida o hielo a
una temperatura razonablemente baja tal
vez esta temperatura de aquí sea menos
10 menos 10 grados celsius y bueno
podemos tratar con celsius cuando
estamos tratando con este cambio de fase
porque realmente solo nos importa la
diferencia de temperatura y no
necesariamente la temperatura absoluta
así que bueno recuerda que un grado
celsius es lo mismo que uno que elvin
porque las diferencias son lo mismo si
estás trabajando con celsius ok así que
vamos a empezar con menos 10 grados
celsius a amp con hielo o agua en estado
sólido y aprendimos que si agregas calor
al agua entonces la temperatura sube si
agregas energía la temperatura sube y
bueno las moléculas al menos mientras
estén en esta red cristalina de hielo
empiezan a vibrar
hasta que lleguemos a que su energía
cinética media aumenta hasta llegar a
este punto donde estamos a cero grados
celsius en este punto de aquí va a ser
cero grados ok y bueno es que este punto
de aquí es el punto de fusión del hielo
ya los cero grados ya habíamos aprendido
que pasa algo bastante interesante el
calor ha añadido al sistema no
incrementa la temperatura del hielo al
menos durante este periodo de tiempo de
aquí hasta acá lo que está pasando es
que la energía térmica está siendo
utilizada para romper la estructura
cristalina y así agregar energía
potencia del hielo hasta derretirlo así
que justo por aquí déjame ponerlo con
este color
justo por aquí tenemos hielo
aquí tenemos hielo ok y hielo hielo a
cero grados celsius y ya después por acá
am ambién déjame ponerlo ahora con este
color este de aquí aquí ya tenemos agua
agua pero a cero grados celsius agua es
decir que al 20 grados puedes tener
ambos agua o hielo y si tienes agua para
convertirlo en hielo lo que necesitamos
es quitar calor al sistema tenemos que
quitar calor al agua y si tienes hielo y
quieres convertirla en agua bueno pues
tienes que poner calor en el hielo y
después el calor está usado nuevamente
para calentar el agua a alguna cierta
velocidad y después a 100 grados celsius
justo aquí va a pasar algo muy parecido
tenemos un cambio de fase muy similar a
esta de aquí abajo donde no se utiliza
el aumento de calor para aumentar la
temperatura es usado para poner energía
potencial de nuevo al sistema así que de
aquí a camps tenemos una cierta energía
potencial y en este punto tenemos
todavía agua agua
100 grados celsius ambite que me ponerlo
con este color
voy a tener agua a 100 grados ok
las moléculas de agua son obligadas a
estar lejos las unas de las otras y de
la misma forma que si estoy forzado a
estar lejos del planeta tierra recuerda
tengo energía potencial porque puedo
caer de regreso a la tierra del mismo
modo las moléculas de agua tienen
energía potencial para retroceder /
decir ahora esta energía de aquí es la
energía necesaria para vaporizar el agua
estamos en el punto de ebullición o de
vaporización del agua entonces aquí
tenemos agua a 100 grados mientras que
por acá ya tenemos vapor vapor a 100
grados
aquí tenemos vapor a 100 grados y bueno
en este punto se transforma el agua en
vapor y después podemos agregar más y
más calor así va a seguir aumentando la
temperatura pero meterás había aprendido
esto hace algunos vídeos parece ser
tengo la intuición pero
que trates con números reales quiero
saber exactamente cuánto calor es
requerido para que pasen todas estas
cosas diferentes y bueno es que justo
para eso am si subimos ahora un poco la
pantalla tengo estos números de aquí
estos números de aquí son específicos
para los estados del agua si miras
cualquier otro elemento o molécula
tendrás valores diferentes para esos
números con los que vamos a estar
trabajando justo ahorita este primer
número de aquí y déjenme atraparlo con
este color este primer número de aquí
este es el calor de fusión del agua es
decir la cantidad de calor que se
requiere para fusionar el agua a cero
grados al hielo a cero grados lo cual es
333 puntos 55 es decir que sí deja de
bajar un poco a la pantalla si yo quiero
ver cuál es la distancia que tengo justo
de aquí acá bueno pues esa distancia va
a ser 333 de aquí hasta acá voy a tener
333 333 yus por cada gramo d
que quieran convertirlo a hielo o por
cada gramo de hielo que queda
convertirlo a agua y de hecho a este de
aquí se le conoce como el calor de
fusión y calor de fusión porque estamos
hablando de fundir algo al mismo tiempo
cuando lo hacemos sólido así que también
podría ser considerado como el calor de
derretimiento son dos palabras
diferentes pero hablan de la misma cosa
dependiendo en la dirección que vayamos
si queremos transformar el hielo en agua
sería calor de derretimiento si queremos
pasar de agua hielo es calor en fusión
pero bueno como hablamos la misma cosa y
tiene el mismo valor se le conoce como
calor de fusión de la misma forma a mí
si subimos ahora de nuevo un poco la
pantalla por aquí tengo el calor de
vaporización del agua y déjame ponerlo
con este color a este de kim es mi calor
de vaporización del agua dicho de otra
manera si bajamos para acá que por
cierto son 2.257 y un programa ahora si
subimos justo por acá estoy hablando de
esto
y tengo de aquí de aquí hasta acá la
distancia que hay de aquí acá son dos
mil 257 mil por cada gramo entonces si
tuvieras un gramo de agua líquida a 100
grados y quisieras convertirlo a agua
vaporizada a 100 grados y claro si
estamos asumiendo que nada absurdos le
va a pasar a la presión y estamos con
una presión constante entonces tendremos
que ponerle 2.257 jules al sistema este
de aquí es mi calor de vaporización
calor de vaporización si tuvieras vapor
de agua a 100 grados y quisieras
condensar lo tendrías que quitar la
misma energía al sistema bien ahora ya
sabes cuánto calor se requiere para cada
uno de estos cambios de fase pero
seguramente estás preguntado qué pasa
con estas partes de aquí este de aquí y
estar aquí es decir cuánta energía se
requiere para calentar un gramo de hielo
por cada grados celsius o kelvin y de
igual manera para el agua
y para el vapor y bueno para eso voy a
subir de nuevo a justo la pantalla
porque aquí tengo la respuesta para eso
se necesita observar el calor específico
del agua bien pues date cuenta que el
calor específico del agua en estado
sólido es decir se necesitan 2.052 a
2.052 por cada gramo y por cada que el
vino o grados hechos que nosotros
aumentemos al sistema es decir 2.05
jules por cada gramo porque el vino esto
cuando estamos en estado sólido cuando
estamos en estado líquido se necesita un
poco más del doble 4.178 yul para
calentar un gramo cada kelvin y cuando
está en estado gaseoso bueno es muy
similar a lo que pasa con el estado
sólido y ahora que ya sabemos esto anp
déjame subir un poco la pantalla porque
quiero que hagamos el siguiente problema
y en esto nos vamos a entretener
bastante imagínate que yo lo que quiero
es saber cuánto calor vamos a necesitar
para transformar 200 gramos
200 gramos de amd gramos de hielo y
déjame ponerlo con este color de hielo a
menos 10 grados celsius
ok hielo esto lo voy a transformar vamos
a pasarlo am qué te parecen 200 no 110
110 grados celsius pero de vapor lo
vamos a transformar en vapor 200 gramos
de hielo al menos 10 grados celsius
yo quiero transformar a 200 gramos de
vapor a 110 grados celsius y bueno lo
primero que quiero que hagamos es pasar
estos 200 gramos de hielo de menos 10
grados a 0 grados para poder utilizar el
calor de fusión así que primero vamos a
pasar a mí déjame ponerlo aquí de menos
10 grados
ok el hielo esto lo voy a transformar ok
a hielo pero
ok y
y para esto lo que voy a necesitar
primero es recordar cuál es el calor
específico
del agua en estado sólido y es justo lo
que tenemos aquí el calor específico del
agua en estado sólido es 2.0 5 llull
para calentar un gramo de hielo un
kelvin así que déjame bajar la pantalla
2.05 ok 2.05 vamos a ponerlo como por
acá am necesito poner que esto va a ser
igual al calor específico del agua en
estado sólido a lo cual lo voy a poner
con este color que es 2.0 5 ok esto es
julie para calentar un gramo un kevin ok
ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por la
cantidad de gramos que nosotros tenemos
de hielo que son 200 gramos ok a esto
hay que multiplicarlo por 200 gramos ok
ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por la
diferencia de temperatura si te das
cuenta vamos a pasar de menos 10 grados
a 0 grados es decir tenemos un cambio de
temperatura de 10 grados ya que hay algo
muy importante vamos a tener un cambio
de temperatura de 10 grados celsius pero
es exactamente lo mismo que tener un
cambio de temperatura de 10 games bean
es decir aquí tenemos llull entre gramos
y kelvin pero es lo mismo para los
grados celsius antes de ponerlo con este
color le voy a poner como 10am grados y
bueno como es lo mismo tener un cambio
de 10 grados celsius que de 10 kelvin am
para no complicarnos la vida aquí le voy
a poner celsius aquí le voy a ponerse el
chus porque esto es igual verdad y bueno
a cuantos igual esto si yo lo que quiero
hacer es calcular justo esta parte de
aquí bueno pues es hora de sacar a
nuestra calculadora y vamos a hacerlo
2.05 a esto lo multiplicó por 200 ya
esto es lo multiplicó por 10 esto es lo
mismo que 4100 jules ok entonces bajemos
éste para acá y lo voy a poner así con
y ahora me gusta utilizar este color voy
a tener un cambio de 4.100 y voy a
necesitar 4100 grados de energía para
transformar 200 gramos de hielo al menos
10 grados celsius a 200 gramos de hielo
a 0 grados celsius y bueno ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que
solamente hemos hecho en esta primera
parte de kim solo hemos trabajado con
esta primera parte de aquí ok lo único
que hemos hecho es pasar de menos 10
grados el hielo a 0 grados el cielo es
decir esta parte de aquí ahora lo que
hay que hacer es pasar de hielo a agua
estos 200 gramos de hielo los voy a
pasar a 200 gramos de agua y para eso
necesito el calor de fusión así que
sumamos un poco más y mi calor de fusión
es 330 y 3.55 jules por cada gramo así
que vamos a utilizar eso ahora lo que
quiero hacer es pasar y déjame ponerlo
justo por aquí ahora lo que necesito es
pasar de hielo a cero grados
a 0 grados lo voy a transformar am agua
a cero grados sigo con 0 grados pero
ahora lo voy a pasar a agua líquida ok y
para eso lo que hay que hacer es
multiplicar y déjame ponerlo con este
color habrá que multiplicar el calor de
fusión que es 333 puntos 55 y déjame
ponerlo con este color 330 y 3.55 jules
por cada gramo ok por la cantidad de
gramos esto por la cantidad de gramos
que son 200 a esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por 200 gramos y esto va a
ser igual a cuánto ok y para eso de
nuevo voy a traer por acá a mi
calculadora que la tengo justo aquí y es
hora de hacer esta siguiente operación
tengo 333 puntos 55 ok a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 200 gramos y esto es lo
mismo que 66 mil 710 ok
déjame pasar está para acá y 66 mil 710
y déjame ponerlo con este mismo color
para que al final nos sumemos 66 mil 710
y jules ok ahora tengo todo transformado
en agua a cero grados ahora lo que
necesito es pasar a mí y déjame ver
estamos justo por aquí tengo agua a cero
grados y vamos a transformar esta misma
cantidad de agua pero a 100 grados y
para eso lo que voy a necesitar es el
calor específico del agua pero en estado
líquido ahora lo que voy a hacer es
tratar con agua en puro estado líquido y
para eso necesito este valor 4.178 llull
por cada gramo y cada kelvin 4.178 y
bajemos la pantalla a 4.178 qué cantidad
tan rara y ahora que estoy justo por
aquí déjenme poner qué es lo que vamos a
hacer vamos a pasar
ok deben poner con este color
agua a cero grados ok agua pero ahora lo
voy a transformar a agua a 100 grados a
100 grados pero también es agua ok y
para esto lo que necesito es multiplicar
el calor específico del agua en estado
líquido aunque vimos que por cierto es
4.178 4.178 yoon-ok / dramón grados
celsius recuerda que estoy pasando los
kelvin a grados celsius ok ya esto hay
que multiplicarlo por bueno la cantidad
de agua que tenemos que son 200 gramos
ok ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por
el cambio de temperatura pero si te das
cuenta aquí estoy transformando agua de
0 grados a 100 grados es decir tengo un
cambio de temperatura de 100 grados y
para eso dejen utilizar este color y lo
voy a multiplicar por
en grados centígrados que es mi cambio
de temperatura y quiero que te des
cuenta de lo siguiente esos grados
centígrados se van a cancelar con estos
grados centígrados
estos gramos se van a cancelar con
nuestros gramos y solamente me quedo con
jules que es justo lo que quiera
queremos saber cuánto calor o cuánta
energía estamos agregando al sistema y
bueno esa es una buena unidad y de nuevo
voy a traer para acá a esta calculadora
la voy a poner por aquí y voy a decir
4.178 por ok 200 por a cien por cien y
esto es lo mismo que 83 mil 560 así que
vamos a apuntar los 83 mil
déjame traer este mismo color y esto va
a ser igual a 83 mil 560 bulls ok 60
este que parezca un 0 muy bien ahora
vamos a ver en donde nos encontramos am
si subo esta pantalla bueno date cuenta
que ahora tenemos el agua a 100
grados celsius pero lo que quiero ahora
es pasarlo todo a vapor porque al final
tenía que terminar con vapor y para eso
lo que necesito es el calor de
vaporización recuerda que aquí no
estamos aumentando la temperatura
entonces vamos a ver cuánto es mi calor
de vaporización lo tengo justo por aquí
mi calor de vaporización son 2.257 y uno
por cada gramo
ok 2.257 así que bajemos esto para acá
ok vamos a bajarle un poco más estamos
justo por aquí ok y déjame ponerlo justo
con este mismo color ahora lo que quiero
es transformar estos 100 grados celsius
de agua es decir tengo 200 gramos de
agua a 100 grados celsius y lo quiero
transformar a 200 gramos pero de vapor a
100 grados celsius 100 grados celsius d
y para eso necesitamos el calor de
vaporización que eran déjame poner que
esto es exactamente igual al calor de
vaporización que por cierto lo tenía con
este color y son 2.257 entonces déjame
ponerlo 2.257 just esto por cada gramo
esto por cada gramo y habrá que
multiplicarlo por bueno la cantidad de
gramos que tenemos que son 200 a esto
hay que multiplicarlo por 200 gramos ok
los gramos con los gramos se cancelan y
habrá que ver cuánto es esto y para eso
de nuevo voy a utilizar mi calculadora
así que la voy a traer para acá ok y
ahora quiero multiplicar 2.257 que es
esta cantidad de aquí por 200 200 y esto
es lo mismo que 451.400 451.400 ok vamos
a ponerlo
y esto es lo mismo que ok 451.400 rules
de lujo ahora regresemos en nuestro
esquema para ver en dónde estamos
todavía no hemos acabado el problema si
te das cuenta tenemos ahora 2 200 gramos
pero ahora son de vapor sin embargo
queremos llegar hasta el 210 grados y
para eso lo que voy a necesitar es pasar
de 100 grados celsius a 110 grados
celsius es decir voy a aumentar 10
grados más y para aumentar 10 grados más
voy a necesitar el calor específico del
agua pero en forma vapor y para eso
vamos a subir un poco y vamos a
recordarlo en vapor el calor específico
del agua es de 1.89 llull para que cada
gramo aumente un grado celsius o kelvin
entonces 1.89 déjame bajar la pantalla y
ahora sí vamos a am
amparán vamos para cada ok ampliando me
que haga así que voy a bajar un poco la
pantalla y voy a poner que ahora lo que
quiero es pasar de 100 grados celsius de
100 grados celsius de vapor lo voy a
calentar un poquito más lo voy a
calentar a 110 grados celsius también en
estado vapor y para eso
lo que necesito es déjame bajar un poco
esto de aquí para que no se montón y no
nos confundamos ok vamos a bajarlo un
poco y ahora sí antes de poner que esto
va a ser igual y ahora si te das cuenta
lo que necesito es el calor específico
del agua pero en estado gaseoso que
quedamos que eran 1.89 perfecto 1 punto
1.89 llull ok esto por cada gramo para
que se caliente un grado celsius ok ya
esto lo voy a multiplicar por la
cantidad de gramos que son 200 déjame
ponerlo con este ecuador esto por 200
gramos ya esto habrá que mucho
riccardo por el cambio en temperatura
que bueno son 10 grados mis últimos 10
grados celsius
ok celsius con celso se van gramo un
gramo y ahora habrá que multiplicar 1.89
por 200 por 10 y eso va a ser igual es
la última vez o no la penúltima vez que
traigo esta calculadora 1.89 lo voy a
multiplicar por 200 gramos ya esto lo
voy a multiplicar por un cambio de
temperatura de 10 grados y esto es lo
mismo que 3.780 ya no es tanto 3.780 así
que voy a sacar el color de las
respuestas voy a bajar un poco más mi
pantalla ok y vamos a ponerlo lo que
esto es igual es a 3.780 jules ok y si
ahora queremos saber la cantidad total
de energía la cantidad total de calor
que tuvimos que poner al sistema para ir
de hielo a menos
es grados celsius hasta vapor a 110
grados celsius estos 200 gramos bueno
simple y sencillamente habrá que sumar
todas estas cantidades que tenemos aquí
y para eso vamos a hacerlo con mucho
cuidado y en orden recuerda justo lo que
tenemos acá arriba lo primero que
hicimos fue pasar de hielo a menos 10
grados celsius hasta hielo a 0 grados
celsius y para eso aún nos quedamos con
el valor de 4.100 jules así que déjenme
traer de nuevo para acá nuestra
calculadora ok y vamos a empezar a sumar
lo primero que hay que sumar son 4100
glass que es esto de aquí 4100 news ok a
esto habrá que agregarle y después que
fue lo que hicimos
pasamos estos 200 gramos de hielo a 0
grados a 200 gramos de agua pero a cero
grados todavía recuerda que estábamos en
esta parte de aquí justo en esta parte
de aquí y para eso te das cuenta lo que
hicimos fue sumar
y es la cantidad que tenemos aquí 66 mil
710 así que traigamos de nuevo a la
calculadora la tengo justo por aquí y a
esto le voy a sumar 66 mil ok 710 jules
ok ahora habrá que sumarle y ahora vamos
a pasar estos 200 gramos de agua a 0
grados a 200 gramos de agua a 100 grados
celsius es decir estamos trabajando con
esta parte de aquí esta parte de aquí
estamos calentando el agua en estado
líquido y la calentamos 100 grados así
que para eso lo que necesitamos fueron a
83.000 justo esta cantidad que tengo
aquí 83 mil 560 así que vamos a sumar la
justo a nuestra calculadora 83 mil 560
ok y después que hicimos a esto habrá
que agregarle am ahora lo que hicimos
fue pasar estos 200 gramos de agua a 100
grados hechos los transformamos a 200
gramos de vapor
misma temperatura 100 grados celsius así
que si subimos aquí recordando nuestro
esquema fue justo esta parte de aquí no
estamos aumentando la temperatura pero
estamos transformando de agua en estado
líquido a agua en estado gaseoso y para
eso necesitamos o ante energía si
bajamos esto nos vamos a dar cuenta que
utilizamos un montón de energía 451 1401
así que saquemos de nuevo mi calculadora
y déjame ponerlo aquí 451 1402 ok y
ahora para finalizar le voy a sumar lo
que hicimos al final pasamos estos 200
gramos de vapor a 100 grados celsius a
200 gramos de vapor a 110 grados celsius
recordando aquí en justo a esta también
está que tenemos aquí lo que hicimos fue
subir un poco más la temperatura del
vapor es decir pasamos de 100 grados
celsius am hasta un valor de por acá no
y déjame ponerlo con este color hasta
este valor de por acá que eran 110
grados celsius ok y para eso
recordemos cuánta energía necesitamos
fueron a tres mil 782 así que saquemos
de nuevo nuestra calculadora ya esto le
voy a sumar tres mil setecientos ochenta
woods y de respuesta me va a dar 600 9
mil 552 wow es una super cantidad 600 9
550 déjame subir un poco la pantalla am
y vamos a ponerla justo aquí y ahora me
fijo en todo el proceso
me dio una cantidad enorme de jules me
dieron a 609 ok 550 luz esa fue mi
cantidad final de energía que nosotros
utilizamos toda esta energía para pasar
200 gramos de hielo al menos 10 grados
celsius hasta 200 gramos de vapor a 110
grados celsius y seguramente me vas a
decir 609.000 es un montón
pero si lo pensamos en kilos jules que
es otra escala son 600 9 kilos jules ok
y eso realmente no es tanto no es una
gran cantidad de trabajo podrías
realizar estos 200 gramos de hielo que
bueno de hecho es la mitad o un poco
menos de la mitad de una libra de hielo
y la podremos poner en la estufa para
que se caliente y esta media libra de
hielo la transformamos a media libra de
vapor de agua y bueno de hecho esto es
algo que probablemente podrías hacer en
la estufa de tu casa